If someone is in the hospital and
they're really sick, there's really
nothing that a clinician can do other
than give them supportive care.
What we've been trying to do is develop
broad-spectrum antivirals that work
not only against the coronaviruses that
we know about today like SARS-CoV-2, the
causative agent of COVID-19, but also we
want these things to have a broad
application against coronaviruses that
might emerge in the future.
A vaccine basically is something that you take as a preventative measure.
So this could be COVID-19 a vaccine against
SARS-coronavirus-2, SARS-CoV-2,
the causative agent of COVID-19.
If we got a vaccine then we
would be our bodies would be protected
from infection by that agent. So what an
antiviral drug does, it's different:
most of the time you're taking these things
after you know you got sick to try and
decrease the symptoms that you might
have and prevent the development of
severe disease. And you might prevent
lots of older people or people that have
underlying health conditions from going
to the hospital
and ending up on a ventilator.
We started working on Remdesivir five or six years ago.
All of that work set this drug up for immediate deployment into human
clinical trials for COVID-19. I think
that's different than like someone who
might find something today. Right? They
have to do all the work that we've been
doing for the past five years before
they can use this drug in a person
or even test it for safety.
There are several human clinical trials
all over the world evaluating the
potential for different antiviral drugs
to have some effect on COVID-19:
Remdesivir, chloroquine, some of the HIV
protease inhibitors, and some of these
other things. We can basically close the
door or open the door on these things
and say this is useful... this is hurtful.
It's hard to know which way the wind is gonna blow